let's say you have some JavaScript code
that lives in a single file you can turn
this code into a module by exporting it
this allows other files to use an import
statement to import this file as a
dependency so a module is nothing more
than a file that exports its own code
this allows developers to organize code
within their own projects or share code
with the world through package managers
like NPM in modern front-end development
it's most common to use es modules which
became an official language feature in
2015 the syntax is also supported in
note 13 but traditionally the way to do
this a node is with required Jas it's a
similar idea but instead we use this
require function to import a module
require is more common now but the
future is es modules a module can export
its code in a variety of ways and this
will affect the way the consumer imports
it a module can export a single default
value multiple values or both if a
module provides a default export it
means the consumer can call import name
from path the importing file can choose
whatever name it wants but a module also
has the option to expose multiple
exports from a single file you can
export them one by one or all together
as a single export list on the other
side the importer will use the exact
name used in the module however it is
possible to rename an import using the
as keyword a huge benefit of named
exports is that they make the module
tree shakable that means the consumer
only imports the code they actually need
resulting in smaller bundle sizes and
better performance you can also combine
the best of both worlds to give you a
hybrid syntax that looks like this it
helps to have a cheat sheet my personal
favorite is the one from Samantha Ming
if you don't already follow her awesome
post on Twitter you definitely should be
this has been yes modules and 100
seconds thanks for watching and I will
see you in the next one